Trascrizione: Marta Fulcheri
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
“Tu non sei solo”.
Queste sono le parole più importanti
che possiamo dire e sentirci dire.
Hanno una forza e una magia
che altre parole non hanno,
talmente tanto che non serve
nemmeno contesto.
Non serve conoscersi, per dircele.
Hanno un potere che va al di là
del loro stesso significato
e che altre frasi non hanno.
Quale?
“Ci crediamo”.
Se io te le dico, ci credi.
Per un attimo, ma è così.
Posso fare degli esempi contrari.
Se io dico “ti amo”
oppure “no, non ti ho tradito”
o in una splendida imitazione di mia madre
“Jeans buttati? Jeans strappati?!
Io non ho buttato
nessun paio di jeans strappati.
Li avranno persi in lavanderia”.
Ecco queste sono cose alle quali
tu non necessariamente credi.
Ma se io ti guardo negli occhi,
al bar, al mare, al parco,
alla fermata dell’autobus,
all’ufficio postale,
e ti dico “tu non sei sola”,
“tu non sei solo”,
tu mi credi, così, istantaneamente.
Eppure non le diciamo mai,
né agli altri né a noi stessi.
Perché?
Cos’è la solitudine?
La solitudine può essere
l’esclusione da ogni rapporto
di vicinanza e presenza altrui,
ricercata come motivo
di pace o intimità,
sofferta, se conseguente all’assenza
di ogni affetto, sostegno e conforto.
In parole più povere,
ce la possiamo immaginare
la solitudine come un ambiente,
uno spazio inabitato, deserto,
pervaso da una sconfinata,
inospitale vastità.
Vista cos’è la solitudine,
allora vediamo cosa non è la solitudine.
La solitudine non è assenza.
L’assenza non è solitudine,
non sono la stessa cosa.
Se io ti dico
“non trovo i miei jeans strappati”,
i miei jeans strappati
sono certamente assenti.
Non necessariamente sono soli,
perché potrebbero essere
nelle mani di chi li ha presi.
Ma se io ti dico “tu hai preso e buttato
senza dirmelo i miei jeans strappati”,
allora forse ti sto dicendo
che mi stai facendo sentire sola
e mi stai anche facendo sentire
quanto siamo distanti,
di più, ogni giorno che passa.
Questo era quelloche pensavo io
durante l’adolescenza,
di non poter scegliere di stare da sola,
ma di continuare incessantemente
a sentirmici sola.
Perché il distacco
dalle figure genitoriali
e in generale da chi si prende cura di noi
non è importante, è fondamentale.
Ci sono diverse fasi
della vita dove va fatto.
Ci si deve distaccare.
Grandi pensatori, studiosi della mente
dicono che metaforicamente
si dovrebbero uccidere i genitori.
Metaforicamente.
Però mi hai rubato i miei jeans
e me li hai buttati. Va beh!
Quando ci troviamo
nelle situazioni della vita dove dovremmo
distaccarci dalla nostra famiglia,
a volte falliamo.
E se falliamo, non potendocene andare,
non possiamo tornare cresciuti,
maturi, adulti, grandi.
Quindi poi non siamo in grado
di impostare paletti e recinti
all’interno delle nostre relazioni,
con la famiglia e con gli altri.
Recinti che servono
a tutelare il nostro io,
per concederlo quando noi
siamo in grado di farlo,
non quando ci viene chiesto.
Se falliamo, ci spezziamo in due.
Il nostro cuore si rompe
e il nostro cervello metaforicamente
si spacca in due parti.
Una è quella che vediamo tutti,
che è più o meno capace,
buona, giusta, onesta.
L’altra è nascosta. È una parte che noi
abbiamo deciso essere senza speranza.
La prima parte sa stare al mondo.
La seconda parte il mondo
lo soffre fino al midollo.
La prima parte va all’ufficio postale,
parla con l’impiegato,
telefona al ristorante
per prenotare una cena,
parla con l’amministratore di condominio,
ci discute per la lampadina al terzo piano
che è ancora fulminata,
fa due chiacchiere con la madre di Marco
fuori scuola, quando accompagna i figli.
La seconda parte di noi è terrorizzata
dalla porta scorrevole
dell’ufficio postale,
non si sente all’altezza di fare
nessuna telefonata, nemmeno al ristorante.
Odia il confronto. Detesta il contrasto.
e, non importa che siano genitori o figli,
non si sente all’altezza di nessuno.
Immaginiamole queste due parti.
La prima vede le persone,
sa di far parte di un gruppo,
comprende il rapporto
di presenza e vicinanza altrui.
La seconda vede le persone,
ma è immersa in un ambiente
nell’assenza assoluta di ogni rapporto
d’affetto, sostegno e conforto,
pervasa da un senso di sconfinata
e inospitale vastità.
La prima parte sa stare da sola.
La seconda si sente sola.
Noi non diciamo mai a nessuno
né a noi stessi
“tu non sei solo”, “tu non sei sola”,
perché c’è una parte di noi
che vive con noi e viaggia con noi
appesantita da ogni singolo istante.
Quella parte di noi che tutti i giorni
a un certo punto arriva e dice
“tu non vali abbastanza”.
“Se ti hanno lasciato c’è un motivo,
è colpa tua di tutto”.
“Dovevi fare di più nella vita,
ma concederti meno”.
“Noi donne dovevamo darla a tutti,
ma poi riprendercela”.
“Noi uomini dovevamo essere migliori
con le donne, ma mai froci”.
Perché in questa parte
noi nascondiamo le nostre difese,
che sono identitarie, di genere,
di razza, politiche, religiose,
e sono razziste,
sono omolesbobitransfobiche,
grassofobiche, abiliste, xenofobe.
Perché come ci si difende dal mondo,
se è sempre colpa tua.
(Sospira)
Noi nascondiamo questa parte di noi
e noi non diciamo
“tu non sei solo”, “tu non sei sola”.
Perché non abbiamo la minima idea
che quello dall’altra parte della strada,
l’impiegato all’ufficio postale,
quello che risponde al telefono
e prende le prenotazioni al ristorante
e la mamma di Marco,
dentro hanno la stessa parte spezzata,
hanno la stessa parte rotta.
E questo è il motivo della solitudine.
Sapere di avere una parte di te
che nessuno ama,
perché nessuno conosce,
perché nessuno vede.
Questo è il problema della solitudine.
Ci sentiamo soli,
perché non ci sentiamo amati.
E non ci sentiamo amati,
perché per credere all’amore di qualcuno
devi avergli detto chi sei.
Sapere di avergli detto
“io sono così per intero”,
sapere che ama le tue mani,
ma anche le tue manie,
lo fanno sorridere perché sono due,
ma entrambe piccole,
che adora i tuoi occhi,
ma anche i tuoi desideri,
perché anche quelli sono due, ma grandi.
Noi non ci crediamo quando
le persone ci dicono che ci amano,
perché non gli abbiamo
fatto vedere chi siamo.
Non lo facciamo mai. Perché abbiamo
una paura fottuta delle nostre debolezze,
delle nostre parti sporche,
delle nostre abitudini,
delle nostre ridicole ossessioni
per le bambole di porcellana,
per i giochi di ruolo con i pupazzetti,
per i pantaloni senza gli strappi.
Quando eravamo piccoli, le nostre famiglie
non ci hanno aiutato a distaccarci.
Per alcuni di noi era chiaro il messaggio
“se te ne vai io non sarò mai più felice”.
Per altri di noi è stato ancora
più complicato tornare cresciuti,
perché nessuno li stava aspettando.
E poi c’è un altro gruppo,
quello più numeroso,
che dei genitori li hanno avuti,
ma così terribili
da fargli scontare a cinghiate,
schiaffi, abusi, umiliazioni e vergogna
ogni goccia della loro infelicità.
L’infelicità di chi
li aveva messi al mondo,
che ancora si vede perfettamente
in una mappa di cicatrici sul corpo
di chi l’ha ricevuta.
Cicatrici così profonde dentro e fuori
che certe ancora si vedono
e certe altre anche. Perché le cicatrici
si vedono tutte e per sempre.
E per questo gli psicoterapeuti
dovrebbero essere ricercati e desiderati
quanto i chirurghi plastici.
Fatto sta, che è da allora che noi
torniamo a casa tutte le sere,
come se fosse un costume di scena,
ci sfiliamo di dosso
la persona che mostriamo
per diventare la persona che ci fa paura.
Ci mettiamo davanti allo specchio,
ci guardiamo e diciamo
“ma chi l’amerebbe mai
una figura così rotta”.
È da allora che abbiamo deciso che
tutte le parti di noi che sono sbagliate,
non perfette, non spolverate,
non lucide, non precise, non profumate,
accoglienti e funzionali
non vanno bene e vanno nascoste.
La verità?
Siamo tutti rotti.
Abbiamo tutti un pigiama di merda.
Perché è brutto
andare a dormire tutte le sere
non sapendo se il problema
sei tu o la persona che hai nascosto
così in fondo da essere
quasi tatuata sulla tua pelle.
Ma la verità è che siamo tutti rotti.
E quelle due parti di te
che tu proprio non riesci a far comunicare
io le vedo, perché le ho anch’io.
E così tutti quelli
con i quali ti rapporti
la mattina, il pomeriggio, la sera,
al telefono, fuori da scuola,
dentro il tuo condominio.
Siamo tutti rotti.
E quindi comincio io oggi a dirti
“tu non sei sola”, “tu non sei solo”
e vorrei che facessi
la stessa cosa che faccio io,
sapendo che c’è una differenza da oggi,
che per ogni volta nella quale
nelle tue parti distrutte
ti sei mangiato le unghie
fino a far uscire il sangue,
la tua vicina di casa
si strappava le ciglia.
Vorrei che tu ti ricordassi che
tutte le volte nelle quali hai deciso
di aprire un account fake per dire
a qualcuno “sei un grasso bastardo”
semplicemente perché eri arrabbiato
per un altro motivo,
il tuo capoufficio cercava continuamente
di aprire la portiera della macchina
dopo averla chiusa con l’allarme.
Vorrei dirti che tutte le volte
che sei tornato e tornata a casa
e hai detto guardando al cielo
“perché mi lasciano tutti?”,
“Dio, ti prego, dimmi perché
nessuno mi ama”,
I genitori di Marco
si stavano urlando le cose peggiori
senza avere il respiro di dirsi
l’unica cosa che gli faceva paura.
“Siamo tutti rotti”.
Quindi oggi comincio io a dirtelo
quello che dico alle mie due parti
tutte le mattine
“Io mi merito l’amore”.
“Perché non è colpa mia da dove vengo,
ma è mia meravigliosa
responsabilità dove sto andando”.
“Non è colpa tua da dove vieni,
ma è tua meravigliosa responsabilità
dove stai andando”.
Fai vedere agli altri chi sei
e troverai qualcuno che lo ama per intero
perché lo condivide con te.
Ovviamente, a meno che tu
odi gli strappi nei jeans.
In quel caso, meriti la solitudine!
Mostra agli altri chi sei.
Perché queste due parti
ce le abbiamo anche noi.
Non è colpa tua da dove vieni,
ma è tua meravigliosa
responsabilità dove stai andando.
E sinceramente, io vorrei
l’onore di venire con te,
perché così almeno saremo in due,
o in quattro se ci andiamo spezzati,
a rendere quella desolata
terra sconfinata una cazzo di festa.
(Applausi)